know october isn't just about renfest of
course it's also spooky season we've got
to hunt the horizon and there are so
many fun things happening around town
the city of henderson starting a home
decorating contest that's happening
right now you have until october 24th to
send a photo of your haunted house the
public is actually going to be voting on
facebook best diy category most family
friendly and winners up for some prizes
you can register on the city's website
tivoli village also getting in on the
halloween spirit the museum of monsters
kicks off tomorrow it will be open
through halloween night you can check
out the undead maze and haunted house as
well at tivoli village every weekend
this month and there's a twisted pumpkin
pop-up bar you can throw back some
halloween themed drinks there through oc
november 2nd we have more details on all
the other halloween events around the
valley at eightnewsnow.com
yeah john moonlighting as a vampire in
moonlighting in everyday lighting
being a vampire is a day-to-day thing i
don't think they do days
this one does
i don't know we get up so early it's
practically night